oh no my name welcome back to data
readily we're back here oh no no we're
walking circle No
shut up sha Chi Chi I come from there
everyone is just sad in this mod well it
looks different now they're not get my
lantern back I swear I got my item
nevermind app um and hi
okay what the hell is annoyed ah really
never stop walking up there prepare
lever and more sword storage is all bad
news so let's go here first all right
puzzles I saw that I saw what
uh-uh all right I fixed that what X 4 C
2 X 4 um I get anything I get anything
never much does that do
pulling levers like about ah I did
something this story is just now open
that's nice
oh the hell is that
ah [ __ ] it's coming oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] cousin
I knew it I know it was fine I knew it
was a pro fire the hell is that oh
that's one close cool all right let's go
to storage I'm sure oh no don't kill me
fada ain't gonn solace all right
I never had this baby this is guys I try
to tell you about that man but I
couldn't do it it's kid fauna sit down
I'll try to all right we don't need a
lantern in here I got flowers
we got man's peeing in the corner keep
doing what you're doing
ladies love it man it's gotta be
something in here about it what are you
I know you would do that try okay I'll
just use that see you later peeing
people don't pee on me
haha hey buddy went today don't I don't
try ah pair the Jesus Christ you suck
man I the darker back on flame on
[ __ ] all right
we don't need you we are going to click
ever now it should be done what is done
is done Lady Gaga the [ __ ] man just put
you there it's gone dry son of a [ __ ]
um don't worry solid you're dry I need
to add moisture but how about we borrow
the guys pee no all right we mixing Bin
Ladin and
I don't see why that wouldn't work dry
dry
hey I hear water forgot about this place
all right perfect
excellent a wet on wet I betcha
all right let's go back I told it all
Bahama don't wanna stop puzzle okay you
brothers did a little bit I'll eat just
to let you watch me I had to find out I
pay to do what you gotta do I always do
what I gotta do no beaten bumper silly
come on man I did it all right this one
is for you as the fauna literally have
no [ __ ] clue when it [ __ ] is dead
and we did it bro did
now we can go to that ah I don't know
where we go
I don't even know what a [ __ ] dead
maybe go back baby got back that's fauna
how'd you go hmm no daddy why you got me
why how'd you fell between the state I
would have been bad all right I guess
would go back and it's not sorry about
this funny
don't worry back baby he thinks that I
know why do that start what did i do i
trigger something
no bad game stop
I get that it's funny I'll leave you
that can't be bothered with you right
now so scary okay fine I'm gonna get you
a son-of-a-bitch barrel what did I just
call Stephano a barrel I think that is
what the hell with it
I may be working with the barrels but I
thought what I mean I'm not working in
the back all right Cole I'll let you go
through there perfect all right you man
the [ __ ] are you man
all right don't - I'm sorry pity it's my
shadow mode I use it to escape barrels
and bras all right I guess that makes
sense
all right Eddie keep going I was
actually keep going
that's cool I must have opened something
huh whoa whoa whoa what's going on let's
go now don't make nice pinning don't
worry here
non-magnetic
what the hell am I supposed to do I
don't like this
Shh did he do it
everything's gonna be alright everything
I know this is not good
I pity I have a plan widen it Shivaya
I don't know what don't talk to me don't
show me your ass audio ha ha what where
you go right out it yeah dad was that
well that was stupid
oh it's david vitter I [ __ ] him off
with my son
good for you man alright what do we have
in here
I had nothing and more nothing
oh and more nothing cool hidin all right
man
you're not even real Stefano have what
shut up
doc complaining it's not that bad
this is others more Stefano Zane
I know what don't fall in my face I'll
define your fake
I don't want you I need you
hi Dwight holy [ __ ] work
huh but don't make nice a pair damn time
hi this is friend fight no way payday
done heck that how did i trigger this
again I hate that part I hate this part
this pie that pie my pie what what ah
you were golden I thought you were the
real sivanna right pear they don't judge
me because I'm not there else tomorrow
it's all okay it's all good it's all
right I am spying on I know you're all
nine Savannah all right baby
don't worry bad it's not gonna be good
I'm not worried all right I just curious
what the [ __ ] I did when I pull that
lemon and salt that brain air puzzle
what are you done I pity it looks like I
find my place now go find stefana and
make me prac
this is just that is weird man I can't
let you do that pip I'm sorry all right
fine you say me pity I was a demon okay
person inside me you told me today all
right I use my Brainiac ideas again and
but you're coming with me I don't care I
will one day we'd be like all right
whatever man just stop talking man all
right baby I'm sorry
let's go here to the manhole what did
manhole okay all right this is not the
way to the manual
to the manly Hall all right whatever
whatever Gonzales all right to the man
man man little pity I don't even know
what you're talking about man
I don't know you there bathing but I
like it I look at that man I don't think
it's his foot can i pearly
no he can't we're going to the manor
alright to the manor know what don't
slide down and break down here baby all
right cool oh this is a manhole fitting
I'm glad you're enjoying it I never said
I enjoyed I'm really glad you're
enjoying it really glad you're enjoying
it bear they barely if that is your real
name
bearing oh [ __ ] it's no better payday
it's not multi no wait a minute
monster no puede left better no you
should have gone straight [ __ ] this ah
no all right laughter that's better
laughter that
that's straight dancer dancer ah drop
just get rowdy better holy shet is
shaking like a vagina
I painted something holy [ __ ] I see
three of you Sanada
now David Zapata ah all right come god
rah Oh God rah I gotta get up I gotta
get on [ __ ] ah keep on falling a little
[ __ ] no crazy crazy
where is it he must have fell down now
that it comes out is man what the hell
what the hell is shaking I'm inside a
vagina right now if she's coming this is
not this [ __ ]
ah no I don't even know how to know
about it
ah stop shaking ha does that mean I'm a
dildo oh no all right whatever
are you alright we're fine we're still
fine hey baby you're so fine you're so
fine you blow my pain to come to the
beach which my lantern and we're to come
in good news right now my going back and
we sounded like a Bears let that they
like about look look like about my bat
bat bat about like about the bottom or
jumping that like a pimp a bit by bit
let darling shut up like about oh this
is a rope this is a Ralph's
better sir Rob this is as a robust it
says Christ floated a rough but I
followed a rough and then down in the
rough Burnett older Shane fine no now
the show chief used to display ash
doors broken I don't think I enough mama
heavy hair song can help
man well that is a convenient I got a
heavy stone right here
let's go inside the meadow let go and
die the metal that's going tiny mouth we
are going inside man haha a pain shaped
Asian let's click a roof on you and I
turn it upside here but I can favorite
enjoy the sky come birthday
I'll subside and stay awesome bros I
know you will I know you will I know you
I all sing I'm not guessing JB that's ok
my huh Shamu you know what
what what what are you doing here what I
did Jeremy I came out down